SO DESPERATE HE LEFT HIS
CHILDREN BEHIND, BUT DOCUMENTING
EVERY SINGLE STEP AS HE TRAVELED
BY PLANE, BOAT, BUS, MOTORCYCLE
AND FOOT TO GET TO LAST.
HOW DID HE DO IT?
CAME ILLEGALLY THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER OF U.S. AND
MEXICO?
HE WAS PUSHED TO THE BRINK AS XI
JINPING TIGHTENS HIS GRIP ON
ZERO COVID.
THE RATE OF CHINESE NATIONALS
SEEKING ASYLUM ELSEWHERE
INCREASING AS A CLIP SINCE XI
CAME TO POWER.
SELINA WANG HAS THE STORY YOU'LL
SEE ONLY OUTFRONT.
>> Reporter: THIS WALL SEPARATES
THIS MAN FROM HIS AMERICAN
DREAM.
HE'S PREPARED TO RISK EVERYTHING
TO CLIMB OVER, ILLEGALLY
CROSSING INTO THE U.S. FROM
MEXICO.
BUT UNLIKE MOST OF THE THOUSANDS
OF ILLEGAL CROSSINGS A DAY ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, HE'S NOT
FLEEING POVERTY OR VIOLENCE
SOUTH OF THE WALL.
HIS JOURNEY STARTED ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE WORLD.
WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING HIM FOR
MONTHS DURING HIS PERILOUS
ESCAPE OUT OF CHINA BY PLANE,
BOAT, BUS, MOTORCYCLE, AND ON
FOOT.
HE RAN A BUBBLE TEA SHOP BACK IN
CHINA.
WHEN COVID HIT, BUSINESS TANKED
FROM CONSTANT LOCKDOWNS.
HE LEFT HIS SON AND DAUGHTER
BEHIND WITH HIS PARENTS, HOPING
TO BRING THEM TO AMERICA ONE
DAY.
CHINA'S UNRELENTING ZERO COVID
POLICY STIFLING NATIONALISTIC
EDUCATION TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS
PUSHED WONG OVER THE EDGE.
>> Reporter: HE'S THE STRONG MAN
ATOP A SURVEILLANCE STATE, ONE
THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC CAN
CONTROL AND TRACK THE MOVEMENTS
OF VIRTUALLY ALL 1.4 BILLION
PEOPLE.
SINCE THE START OF THE PANDEMIC,
CHINA HAS KEPT ITS BORDERS
SEALED, A POLICY THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS IS NEEDED TO FIGHT
COVID-19.
AND EARLIER THIS YEAR, FOR BADE
ITS CITIZENS FROM GOING OVERSEAS
FOR NONESSENTIAL REASONS.
WITH CHINA TURNING INCREASINGLY
INWARD, WONG BECAME DESPERATE TO
GET OUT, AND HE WAS SET ON ONE
DESTINATION -- AMERICA.
>> Reporter: THROUGH ONLINE CHAT
GROUPS, HE DISCOVERED A NETWORK
OF PEOPLE IN CHINA PLANNING TO
ILLEGALLY EMIGRATE TO AMERICA
THROUGH ECUADOR.
HE APPLIED FOR A LANGUAGE SCHOOL
IN ECUADOR AND MADE IT OUT OF
CHINA IN APRIL WITH THE SCHOOL'S
ADMISSION LETTER AS PROOF.
HE STARTED DOCUMENTING HIS WHOLE
JOURNEY.
FROM ECUADOR, HE RODE BUSES OVER
1,000 MILES TO COLOMBIA, THEN
TOOK A BOAT TO PANAMA, SHARING
THE RIDE WITH OTHER DESPERATE
BUT HOPEFUL MIGRANTS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, A FIVE-DAY
HIKE THROUGH PANAMA'S RAIN
FOREST, AN ENDLESS WALK THROUGH
RIVERS AND MOUNTAINS, A JOURNEY
THAT WONG SAID ALMOST BROKE HIM
FROM EXHAUSTION.
A BRIEF RESPITE AT A REFUGEE
CAMP, THEN SEVEN DAYS OF BUSES
FROM PANAMA TO COSTA RICA,
NICARAGUA, HONDURAS, THEN
GUATEMALA.
FROM THERE, A BOAT TO MEXICO'S
BORDER, WHERE POLICE DETAINED
HIM FOR FIVE DAYS.
WHEN HE WAS RELEASED, HE PAID AN
ILLEGAL SMUGGLER THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO GET TO MEXICO CITY.
DOZENS OF PEOPLE SQUEEZED INTO
THE BACK OF A TRUCK, THEN PACKED
INTO A VAN, MORE THAN 104
DEGREES FAHRENHEIT INSIDE.
IN MEXICO CITY, WONG RODE A
MOTORCYCLE 1,600 MILES TO THE
U.S. BORDER, WHERE WE MET UP
WITH HIM, DETERMINED TO MAKE IT
TO THE OTHER SIDE.
ACCORDING TO THE U.N. REFUGEE
AGENCY, THE NUMBER OF CHINESE
NATIONALS SEEKING ASYLUM HAS
BEEN STEADILY INCREASING UNTIL
IT REACHED A RECORD IN 2021.
AND MOST OF THEM, 70%, WERE
TRYING TO GET TO AMERICA.
ON CHINA'S INTERNET, SEARCHES
FOR EMIMMIGRATION STARTED
SKYROCKETING IN MARCH HAS MANY
STRUGGLED TO GET BASIC
NECESSITIES AND FOOD DURING
LOCKDOWNS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
DISCUSSION FORUMS WITH DETAILED
TIPS ON HOW TO LEAVE CHINA HAVE
GONE VIRAL ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IMMIGRATION LAWYERS SAY
INQUIRIES FROM CHINESE WANTING
TO LEAVE HAVE SURGED SINCE THE
PANDEMIC.
BUT FOR OTHERS LIKE WONG, HE
SAYS THEIR ONLY PATH INTO
AMERICA IS THE ILLEGAL WAY.
HE ULTIMATELY MADE IT TO THE
OTHER SIDE, WALKED HOURS IN THE
AMERICAN DESERT OVER MOUNTAINS.
HIS SNEAKERS FELL APART.
MORE THAN A MONTH LATER, WE MET
WONG IN LOS ANGELES.
IN THIS NEW WORLD, HE'S FOUND
THE FAMILIAR.
IN THE BEST CASE, IT WILL BE
YEARS BEFORE HE SEES HIS FAMILY
AGAIN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN?
HAVE YOU TOLD YOUR FAMILY WHERE
YOU ARE?
>> Reporter: THAT FUTURE IS
UNCERTAIN CERTAIN, BUT WITH
CHINA IN HIS PAST, HE HAS HOPE
OF LIVING OUT HIS AMERICAN
DREAM.
>> ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE REPORT,
SELINA.
I KNOW AS THIS REPORT WAS
AIRING, MUCH OF IT WAS BLACKED
OUT IN CHINA, AND THEY PUT UP
CLAIMING NO SIGNAL.
BUT THE MAJORITY OF THAT REPORT
DID NOT AIR WHERE YOU ARE DUE TO
CENSORS.
HOW IS THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
REACTING TO CASES LIKE WANG'S?
>> YEAH, ERIN.
IN OUR CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW,
IT IS STILL BEING CENSORED AND
BLACKED OUT.
IT SAYS THERE'S NO SIGNAL HERE.
WE HAD REACHED OUT EARLIER TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO
COMMENT ON OUR STORY, AND
BEIJING DEFENDED THE COUNTRY'S
COVID POLICIES AND CALLED CHINA
A LAND FULL OF VITALITY AND
HOPE.
YOU KNOW, STORIES LIKE WANG'S,
THEY ARE A SMEAR ON BEIJING A
NARRATIVE THAT CHINA IS GETTING
STRONGER AND MORE PROSPEROUS
WHILE AMERICA IS IN DECLINE.
WANG'S JOURNEY MAY BE RARE AND
EXTREME, BUT WE HAVE SPOKEN TO
OTHERS THAT ARE TAKING A SIMILAR
PATH, INCLUDING ONE MAN WHO
ILLEGALLY ESCAPED CHINA BY
WALKING ACROSS THE BORDER INTO
VIETNAM.
FROM THERE HE FLEW INTO ECUADOR
AND IS NOW TAKING THAT SAME PATH
AS WANG DID INTO THE U.S.
THROUGH THE U.S./MEXICO BORDER.
OF COURSE THERE ARE STILL PEOPLE
IN CHINA WHO SUPPORT THE ZERO
COVID POLICIES HERE, ERIN, BUT
MORE AND MORE ARE FEELING THE
SENSE OF HOPELESSNESS ABOUT
THEIR FUTURE, A COUNTRY HERE
WHERE THEY SEE THEIR FREEDOMS
AND OPPORTUNITIES DISAPPEARING.
ERIN.
>> THANK YOU VERY MU